Yes, Joe, it's great to see
you man. I appreciate it. Well,
we were in a film together so we've
been like right next to each other on
cellular Lloyd. What someone we
in. Um, that was the culture.
Hi Brett Harvey and it's a, you, me,
Richard Branson and snoop Dogg.
Oh, good company. Yes. Right.
Yeah. So you were just saying
right before we did the podcast,
you were in bed for 15 years.
I was in, I got sick in 1988.
I wasn't able to make it out of
that bed until 2003, but Joe,
I was absolutely certain I would
never make it out of that bed.
What did you have?
It's called these days.
This month it's called m e cfs.
Uh,
up until now it was just known
as chronic fatigue syndrome cfs.
But it's real serious if
you get a bad case of it.
So I was too weak to talk for
five years too weak to talk.
You didn't talk at all?
Not a bit.
I didn't have the strength to
puff out even a syllable. Um,
and um, I was too weak to have another
person in the room with me for five years.
You can have a person in the room.
My stress levels were off the charts and
the slightest thing would just a crack.
My wife tried to keep me company so we
have this big king sized bed and she
would lay in bed reading a newspaper
and the sound of the page turning went
through me like a cannon ball and she,
it just tore me to pieces and she had
to build a separate room in the front of
the house and live there because
I couldn't tolerate anything.
Did you think it was over?
Yeah. I thought first of all,
something you don't know,
you have a sense of humanity and you
don't know it and something like this that
wipes out your entire future.
Every dream,
the overhead for yourself robs you of
your sense of humanity and you don't know
there is a sense of humanity
until it disappears.
So it took me three years.
I had a rebuild a personality from just
about scratch because of the one area I
could handle at least most
of the time was the internet,
you know,
the Internet hit the music industry in
1983 and I had been lusting after it for
years because only academics had
access to this real high tech thing.
And um,
I had,
it took me three years to realize that
every day I was trying to go up to my
front room office and work and that
sitting was draining me of my energy.
And since I only had a
tiny amount of energy,
if I lay there horizontal in the bed,
my voice would eventually come back.
So I had an assistant take two computers
because in those days to computers was
about half the size of the
processing power was half
the size of your cell phone.
And I had him hook up two
computers and a Chinese box.
Don't let anybody tell you the,
and Chinese don't event things they do.
And this was a box that allowed me to
control both computers from one monitor
and one keyboard.
So we have the keyboard up on foam
bolsters so that I could see it when I was
laying perfectly horizontal in bed so I
could still see the keys and I rebuilt a
personality online cause I couldn't get
any further than to the bathroom and
back. That was it. What do you mean
by you rebuilt a personality? Well,
everything I hadn't expected.
I mean I was going to write my
first book and I was going to,
I'm a nerd from science.
I got into science at the age of 10
I got into theoretical physics and
microbiology.
I felt built my first Boolean Algebra
machine when I was 12 I code is down to
computer,
the one science fair awards.
When I was 12 I was taken to see the head
of the graduate physics department at
the University of Buffalo and
disappeared into his office for an hour.
My mother wondered what in the world had
happened to me cause it was supposed to
be a five minute courtesy call.
We were discussing big bang versus steady
state theory of the universe for an
hour. And, uh, when I was 16,
I worked at the world's largest cancer
research lab and I came up with up with
the theory of the beginning,
middle and end of the universe,
the Big Bang theory or the balloon Tory,
it'll model that predicted 38
years in advanced arc energy.
And then I ended up in the rock and
roll business with this background.
So when I imagine I was
going to write my first book,
I was going to leave the rock and
roll business behind because my field
expedition and rock and roll,
I'd learned,
I thought as much as I was
ever going to learn from it.
And I'd worked with Michael Jackson,
Prince Bob Marley, Bette Midler,
ACDC or Smith Quist Piss Queen,
Billy Joel, Billy idol, Paul Simon,
Peter Gabriel, David Byrne, people like
that. What, what caused this disease?
Like nobody knows.
Nobody has a clue. Yeah.
What the, so in the different
names, chronic fatigue syndrome,
Sammy is Myalgic encephalomyelitis
and a more dignified name
dude. Can they understand it and to the
point where they could chest for it.
Did they give you a blood test
or they just can't test for it?
They don't know what causes it.
There's no Ivrit.
A friend approached me
at one point and said,
the Duchess of Kent has what you have.
Can you write her a letter
about how to manage it?
So instead of a letter I wrote 14
or 16 pages or something like that.
So when people have this,
I send them this pamphlet.
It explains how I got out of it,
but we'll work for me.
Is not necessarily going to
work for you or anybody else.
Was it a gradual slipping away of
your energy or was it a gradual?
It happened on March 10th of 1988
so March 9th year fine. March 10th. Okay.
March 9th. I'm fine. March
10th I'm fine. I fly down to a,
I think it was Richmond
or something like that,
to go out five to be taken by jeep,
uh,
five hours into the countryside to
meet with Linda Womack that Sam Cooke's
daughter and her husband,
Cecil Womack,
who is broke the rolling stones first hit,
he and his brother and they have this
big aircraft hanger sized farm building.
Uh, it's going to be their home, but
right now they've just had it built.
It's empty. It doesn't have
heating yet and it's March 10th.
It's still the end of winter.
And so we go and pass the sheep and into
this building and there's no furniture
in there.
And I sit there and interview them for
five hours and find out that there's
something called a black coal mining
culture and that Gospel came out of those
black coal mines. I had no idea that
blacks ever got involved in coal mines,
much less that. That's how
gospel culture began. And I,
they drove me five hours
back to the airport again.
I sat there on the plane with my little
TRS, 100, the very first laptop computer,
this little Gizmo that ran
off of Aa batteries and um,
and then I forgot my,
my laptop on the plane.
I don't do things like that.
Someone who was a little off the next day.
I thought I had a cold.
My technique for handling a cold
work your fucking ass off, um,
walk a minimum of two and a
half miles and do your work.
So I worked in power to my
way through it by Tuesday. Um,
I was so weak that my staff had picked
me up under the armpits and drag me off
to the elevator and throw me in the back
of a car service car and shipped me out
to park slope to my
brownstone in Brooklyn Guide.
Don't know how I even got up the stairs
and it was all downhill basically from
there for 15 years. 15
freaking years. Right. But so,
but I still had, I had gotten
halfway through writing my
first book. My plan was,
okay, I'll do what I've done
with all my rock and roll bands.
When my book is ready to come out.
I'll go do every morning television show,
every radio show,
every newspaper in the country.
I'll stay at high houses where the
sheets are sunny and yellow and um,
where they make the bed for you.
You don't have to make it yourself and
they'll feed you food and stuff like that.
And I'll promote my book. That was my
vision of my next step in life. My Future.
Well, if you can't leave your
bedroom, that's all gone.
That's all gone.
And you have to,
and I had to walk into my
office one day and say,
I have no idea of what's happening
to me. I could be dying. Um,
I have to be out of here in two weeks.
And I gave the whole thing to my staff,
the biggest PR firm in the music
industry. He just gave it to them. Yeah.
And the next day I got a call from a west
coast competitor offering me a lot of
money and I had to say, no, I'm sorry.
I gave it to my staff yesterday. So,
and, and, and I, as I say,
had to reinvent myself with what little
I had. The books were still a value.
My science was still a value and
I had to create a new me online.
Now when you say create a new you online
and you say create a new personality,
what do you, what exactly do
you mean by that? Like, well,
I have your old personality.
All personality couldn't walk anymore,
couldn't talk anymore. That was
your body. That was my body.
But you have no idea of just how much of
your personality is your body and your
vocal cords and stuff like that that
you take for granted are instruments of
some internal you I had to invent
an existence, let's put it that way.
Um, online. And how'd you do that? Like
when, when you say, well, I got on,
I got on line. Um, first I, God,
I can't even remember what came
first, but at some point, um,
because I was fact checking my first book,
but how to do this all laying there in
bed. Um, I got hold of Napoleon, Sean,
y'all, who is the, the anthropologist
who chronicled the fierce people,
the Auto Mama in South America,
people who are really, I mean you,
the more people you kill, the more
wives you get. It's as simple as that.
And y'all know,
I'm old culture and um,
I wanted him to read my book,
my first book,
the Lucifer principle of scientific
expedition into the forces of history.
And he said, look, people are out
to destroy my career right now.
I can't get involved with
anything controversial,
but I'm a key member of the human behavior
and evolution society and you should
be a member.
While he introduced me to a social group
in which I could interact as long as I
can continue to type.
So this is a message board or um,
it was all done via email.
So just a,
a group of people that you
could interact with, with the,
and I've been working on my writing since
I was 16 years old. Science is my base.
But the book I got at the age of
12 by Albert Einstein, you know,
sometimes a book grabs you by the lapels
and it feels like the authors writing
this directly into your face.
And Einstein said to be a genius.
It's not enough to come over,
come up with a theory,
only seven men in the world
who can understand to be a
genius who would have to
be able to come up with that theory and
then express it so clearly that anyone
with a high school education and a
reasonable degree of intelligence can
understand it. So Albert Einstein,
my heroes said, schmuck, listen up.
You want to be on an
original scientific thinker?
You have to be the best
writer you can possibly be.
So I've been working on my writing
since I was 16 years old. I was late.
It took me four years to get around
to doing it after Einstein gave me the
orders and I'm one when I was put on the
human behavior and evolutionary society
group,
well I can write my fucking ass off.
So people were impressed
and they gathered a round.
Me.
Fortunately now admittedly it's all
on a computer screen and it's all via
keyboard and there are no living
humans in the room and he applies.
But it saved my life
to be able to do that.
And then I found it to international
scientific groups of my own and I wrote
three books because those were things I
could do with that keyboard as long as I
have the strength to do the keyboarding
and I didn't always have the strength to
even lift my hands and do that.
But I did most of the time.
Now during this time
were you getting treated?
Were doctors giving you the doctors
don't know a damn thing about this?
Eventually,
my first wife who I lost because of this
loss of 34 year marriage because of the
illness,
she persuaded a cfs doctor or a doctor
who specializes in chronic fatigue
syndrome to come out to my house when
he was going to a party in Brooklyn and
see me.
And the most useful thing that he did was
hand me a piece of paper with an email
address on it. And he said,
this is another one of my
patients. She's in Texas.
I want you to get in touch with her.
And the two of us went out like
Hansel and Gretel, holding hands,
going into the forest,
looking for treatment modalities.
We're looking for treatments that might
possibly save us from our illness.
So when I tell people this
stuff I take and they say, okay,
how can I get this room? And I send them
to my doctor, my old cfs doctor, he says,
oh, I don't give those treatments.
Well, he gave them to me,
but he gave them to me because those
were the things that felt like they might
work and he allowed me to try them.
And I ended up with a,
every morning I give myself a shot
with three different things in it,
half a cc of magnesium,
one cc of Oxytocin,
and a about two CC's of Santa Cobalamin,
which is liquid vitamin B's.
Well, so be 12 magnesium
and oxytocin. Oxytocin,
the bonding hormone,
oxytocin,
the stuff that creates trust
in neuroeconomics experiments.
Oxytocin with, if you're a mother and
you've just given birth to a baby,
when you put that baby to your left
nipple for the very first time,
you feel in some cases like you've just
taken LSD because this chemical goes
coursing through your body and it's a
trip and it makes you trust everybody in
the room.
And everybody who walks into the room,
it's oxytocin and oxytocin.
I been on oxytocin now
for 20 years and Oxytocin,
it turns out also does something else.
Um,
there's this little experiment
called parabiosis, an old rat.
His brain is aging as hard as aging.
His kidneys are aging.
You Hook up the circulatory system to
the circulatory system of a young rat.
And guess what starts happening to the
old rat. His brain starts reversing,
getting, getting younger. His
heart starts getting younger.
His kidneys start to get younger. So
I'm about to be 75 years old in a month.
And um, I do between 400 and
700 pushups in the morning.
First thing, that's crazy.
Yeah, that's really crazy.
But when they tried to figure out what
is reversing the aging and the muscles of
the rat, the heart of the
rat, the brain of the rat,
the one ingredient they were able to
isolate and then use on other rats to get
them to get younger instead
of older was oxytocin.
So in all probability,
the reason I can do between 400 and 700
pushups in the morning at the age of 74
and when I was 19,
the most I could do was 92 and I
was working really hard at it. Um,
is the oxytocin. So I'd never heard of
anybody taking that as a supplement.
Well,
it showed up.
There was a doctor named something like
Seastrunk in Texas who was using it on
cfs patients. And my friend,
the Texas patient of my doctor,
um, found Seastrunk and got his
protocol out of him. In other words,
exactly what he'd used
to treat the problem.
And we gave it to my doctor and he sat
on it for six months until he could
regurgitate it as his own bright idea.
And then,
and then he prescribed it for me.
And it's done wonders that,
and a bunch of other stuff
have done absolute wonders.
What are the other things that have
worked? I think Gabapentin without that.
I mean I was on my way to Moscow
once I finally got out of bed,
I was going to address an international
conference of quantum physicists about
why everything they know about
quantum physics is wrong. And um,
I was fine.
All,
I mean this was my first traveling since
I'd gotten out of bed and it was taking
a huge chance cause it was a huge chance
on throwing me back into bed again.
And I flew all the way to
Germany and was doing just fine.
I was exhilarated that
I was doing so well.
And then halfway between
Germany and Moscow, the cfs
symptoms began to come back.
And that was scary.
And then I reviewed what I was doing and
I realized I'd missed all my afternoon
pills and I,
and as soon as I was able,
well my, we had to find a, a bed
in the infirmary, which is scary.
And the Moscow airport because there are
people walking around with machine guns
and military uniforms and they want to
take my passport away in order to allow
me to lay on a bed in the infirmary.
And so I could be
disappeared at any second.
But when we finally got to our
hotel and opened up my drug role,
um, I took the Gabapentin and within
15 minutes the symptoms were gone.
Wow. So did, have you ever tried
to isolate individual ones?
It removes some of them from the
protocol to see if once removed one
amytriptolene it's an
antidepressant. That's what it
was originally designed for.
And I figured I don't need this anymore.
I'm perfectly healthy.
It was a big mistake.
I started having these blinding
stomach aches and they went out for a,
I mean for months and months and months
until I finally got fed up and started
researching on Google. What do you do
about summer cakes? Well, guess what?
One of the primary things you do to
stop stomach cases. Amitriptyline,
the very thing I had gone off of,
so I had to go back on it.
So it's a whole network,
a mesh of supplements,
drugs,
and lifestyle.
I don't the way normal people sleep.
I sleep from four o'clock in the morning
until eight o'clock in the morning.
I get up,
I listened to magazines on the kindle
while I'm taking my bath and shaving and
all that stuff.
I meet with my assistant,
I give her her marching
orders for the day.
I go back to sleep at 11
and I sleep until three,
and then I get up for my second work day.
Um,
and that's when I do all my writing
and all that kind of stuff. So you do,
you sleep in four hour chunks.
You four hour chunks because
that is better for you.
My body was refusing to
do the eight hour thing.
So one of the first symptoms
of, of cfs is insomnia. Okay.
Now, Joe, if your body is refusing
to sleep for eight hours straight,
listen to your body,
give it what the hell it wants.
And so these are the hours
my body demanded. Um,
and they,
I had been working often until eight
o'clock in the morning from roughly 11
o'clock at night or something like that
and losing track of time and it was very
disorienting. And once I started
this two periods of sleep, a day,
my day stabilized. Um,
and there's other stuff.
I mean listening to
Pandora you would think,
what does that have to do
with your illness? Well,
I work at a cafe that's a vital part of
things because I'm surrounded by people
and I've slowly build community in this
cafe, other workaholic writers like me,
a neuroscientist,
a novel novelist,
and all kinds of people who just sit
there and slave away all day. And,
but I'm listening to Pandora that gives
me a sense of life for some reason.
It's as it's as positive
as an elixir would be.
Um, and it gives me a sense of control
over my environment and I don't hear the
conversations going on around me,
so I can really focus on my work.
I've written four books
this way so far in cafes,
all of this stuff walking five
miles a day. I'm in two bursts.
I mean there I am going through a meadow
in the middle of a park at night. Uh,
how many New Yorkers do you know who
go out and walk through a park in the
middle of the night? Rob's, yeah,
right. That's what you'd think.
But I have the time of my life looking
up at the stars that live middle of the
meadow and being where
I'm not supposed to be.
And you're not supposed to go through
the park at night? Well they let you. Um,
I have been thrown up six times by
the police because I've overseen,
I've overstepped the boundaries.
I've been out there after one o'clock
and they do close the place at one and
throw us all out.
But no win in New York Lore,
unless you're walking a really big dog,
you do not go out and
to parks at night and,
but do you put this whole lifestyle
together and it's not just any individual
ingredient that's making me better.
I'm happier than I was when I was 19.
I'm stronger than I walk a lot
more slowly than when I was 19.
But in terms of push
ups and other exercises,
I'm stronger than I was when I was 19
years old. That is a crazy journey.
Howard.